- My band is since "Idol."
Most of them.
- Are you kidding me?
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Especially Jason.
- I love it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Hi, guys!
- You smell good!
(audience cheering)
- Thanks, Angel.
- Angel!
I was like that star thing.
Yeah, I love that.
It smells so good.
- She said "The star thing."
- It looks like the little star thing.
- It does.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I spray so much of it
that I go through a
bottle like in two weeks.
- You know what?
I can't do it.
It doesn't last on me.
I spray perfume and nobody's ever, like...
- You're not spraying enough, Kels.
- [Kelly] I know, but then I feel like...
- You gotta (imitating spray bottle).
- Okay, I'm not good at it.
I need lessons.
Congratulations on the Golden Globe nom.
That's incredible.
- Thank you.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Oh my God.
- I mean we're both from the same show.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's like, I never
thought I'd be doing this.
You never thought, like
I never even thought
I'd be in an Emmy category.
Never think you'd be in these categories
that we're in.
- No.
- Like is this just blowing your mind?
- It's like a dream.
Like when my husband...
I was in LA.
I was stuck in LA, I was
supposed to be in New York.
And yeah, they kept
pushing the flight back.
But my husband, we talk every morning.
That's my best friend.
And I called home and
everybody was screaming.
So I hung up.
(all laughing)
- It is too early.
- 'Cause I thought something was wrong.
- Oh, you were like, "No bad news."
- No bad news.
So I called back and I'm like,
"Baby, you gotta calm down.
Tell me what's wrong."
He's like, "You got nominated
for a Golden Globe!"
And literally, here's what I did.
(Fantasia sobbing)
- Oh my God!
My favorite part is that you hung up.
- (laughing) I had to.
- Bye.
- I didn't know that something
like this could happen for...
You know, we just love to sing.
- That's what I'm saying.
You had like a dream
and then it kind of...
You said yes to opportunities that made...
Well actually, you didn't
say yes to this opportunity
at first.
- No.
- Which is crazy to me
because you play her
on Broadway.
- Broadway.
- You're incredible on Broadway.
And like, it seems like
such a natural progression.
Why'd you say no at first?
- It was so heavy on Broadway, Kels.
- [Kelly] Just day in, day out, that roll?
- Eight shows a week, plus
my life was a bit crazy then.
So it felt like I was carrying
my cross and her cross.
- Yeah.
- And that was a overload.
- And so this time when
Scott called, I was thinking,
"Did you not see all the interviews
when I said I would never ever come back?"
(all laughing)
- Felt challenged by it.
- Yeah.
And he just said, you
know, "You're our Celie."
Our director, Blitz, he
called and when he told me
he was giving Celie an
imagination, I said, "I'm in."
Because we all have an imagination
and when we're in bad places,
we imagine ourselves in better places.
- Yeah, you need it.
- Yeah.
So I was like, "I'm all in."
On Broadway, you didn't get to see
how she worked out her stuff.
She goes through, goes
through, goes through and then,
♪ And I'm here ♪
And everybody's like, "Yay!"
But how did you get here?
- Yeah.
- So I was just very excited
that they gave her an imagination.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering and applauding)
And it's hard when you're
going through life stuff.
I was talking to Jason about that too.
You go through life stuff
and you have to compartmentalize
and also do your job.
So that's hard.
- It's hard.
- And when you're in a better place
you're like, "I won't go there.
Why would I do that?"
Get it, get it, get it, get it.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Do you, I'm just curious,
'cause I was forced to,
'cause I had to do something
and say yes to something.
Like to let them see it.
Have you ever seen you on "Idol?"
Do you ever watch yourself on "Idol?"
Like, have you ever done that?
- I do.
You know, a good glass of
wine always sends me back.
(audience laughing)
I kid you not.
- Girl.
- My husband's here.
I will literally go back.
(audience applauding)
Now, and I dunno if you like
me, I hate watching myself.
- I hate watching myself.
- With a passion.
But if I've had a good glass of cab...
(audience laughing)
- There's not enough
wine in the world to...
Like literally I watched it.
I had to watched it and I found...
Dude, I feel like if I got
through that I can do anything.
Yes, anything.
- Gimme another one.
- Anything, anything.
I was like, "I did that."
And it was hard, I was tired.
- Yes.
I was over it a lot.
- I know.
Anyway, let's do another short
commercial break, everybody.
"The Color Purple" is in
theaters Christmas day.
Y'all gotta check it out.